fleet brains was a longtime adviser to
Hillary Clinton he joins us tonight so
Philippe we've been doing this Russia
story for more than a year I paid pretty
close attention I keep a running list of
things we have learned this is a pretty
complete list of what we've learned okay
so we've learned that Paul Manafort kind
of sleazy and his business dealings we
learned the Mike Flynn probably should
have had a lawyer when he talked to the
FBI we learned that Donald Trump's aides
agreed with their boss that we should
change our Russia policy that they
called Russian diplomats as is their
prerogative we learned that Russia
bought a hundred grand in facebook ads
and that our tea is funded in part by
the Putin government I knew all of that
before where's the collusion part that
justified this whole exercise well
that's the part that Robert Muller is
still looking at and I don't know why
looking at this a year is some kind of
crazy long time look at whitewater can't
start took over four years to get that
done right look at the Benghazi
committee is it four years again is the
is the whitewater investigation do you
think a model that you'd like to see
replicated I think that robert muller
was picked for this job because of his
dignity and because of his ability to
look at the facts he happens to be a
Republican he was picked by Republican
attacking Muller I would let him know
look and he is you haven't seen this
show call for him to be fired or
anything like that I I'm more interested
in though because he's not who've been
barking like dogs for the last year
about how Russia's subverted our
election our democracy itself is
imperiled Donald Trump was in league
with Russia you know if any of that were
true I'd be upset about it none of that
turns out to be true and no one is
admitting that they were wrong it was
all a lie and admit that they're there
to I don't think that that's true there
are two things here there's whether
Russia meddled in our election and there
is whether Donald Trump's campaign had
anything to do that this is what Robert
Muller is looking at the collusion
partner let's give him time he's
following the facts he obviously found
something Mike Flynn he's the
president's first national career
adviser pled guilty and not to come
whatever lawyer he plead could put on
that well that would so don't stop what
did he plead guilty to did he plead
guilty she's perjury he pled guilty to
why
when to lying to look I'm not here to
defend the impeachment of Bill Clinton
or the Whitewater investigation you live
through both of them and I think they
would have given you a keen appreciation
for how far afield these investigations
can go and the costs the American public
not just financial either to those
investigations so I guess that's kind of
the point I'm making if there's
collusion this what about Benghazi
predicates went on for four years eight
congressional committees all held by
Republicans my point I don't remember
anyone not sitting I'm not you know I'm
not here to say that the Benghazi
investigation bore fruit my point is
I've got intuitive you tonight but I've
never said anything other than that the
charge here is that the Trump campaign
colluded with a foreign government to
subvert the democracy the United States
that's treason that is a charge that was
repeated by a lot of leaders on the
Democratic side in Congress not just
crackpots on you and Steve banning it
and maybe Steve banning too and there's
no evidence of it and isn't it time now
that people to start demanding like
shouldn't we have evidence to back up
the outrageous claims that we know what
robber Muller does or doesn't know he's
doing his job his job is not to tell us
ever it is just it's the entire American
press course but nothing else matters
right now except for Bob Muller this is
his job is to get to the bottom of does
it bother you look in the end it bothers
me that we won't give him the time and
space to do his job at a lot of time and
total space I mean he's had an unlimited
budget he can hire whomever he wants
here's your statute or expiration date
on that exactly the people well but
people under investigation targets and
subjects of course they don't like but I
look as an American get to American
who's lived through this yourself would
it bother you if at the end of this
investigation you get people for crimes
committed before the campaign like Paul
Manafort or you get people like general
Flynn who got caught in a misstatement
the FBI gets a perjury charge but there
was nobody charged for the core
allegation so far collusion so far do
you believe that someone will be charged
I believe we're gonna find out because
we're gonna give Robert Rowley the time
or he's going to take the time and
there's difference between Manafort and
Flynn and Papadopoulos these guys Flynn
what he did was immediately before
or the campaign in during the campaign
Papadopoulos was during the campaign
these are not 10 year old charges like
they are for mannerisms look I'm not
here I'm Papa the Papadopoulos kid the
the Model UN
he's fetch a fever I mean let's be real
okay papa
I mean Flynn was a real guy he was a key
foreign policy advisor to the president
who's Nash secure advisor for 23 days
that's exactly right and a key foreign
policy adviser on the campaign
Papadopoulos I had nothing to do with
anything
okay sighs you know and Flynn's led bill
TM to lying during an interview but it's
possible that he that's told the
authorities it possible anymore that
he's done anything that is actually
harmful to US national security to our
traditions of democracy yes legally and
otherwise I think I think these guys are
lucky that naivete is not criminal
because they allowed for a year the
Russians to ping them time and time and
time again to play them but did these
almost worse that they might not realize
a single piece of evidence they did
something substantially wrong not naive
not stupid
not importantly what was he wrong I'm
confused I think meeting with agents of
the Russian government to provide
opposition research on a presidential
candidate huh it's probably not the most
really things out there with paying
money to a law firm which paid Russian
agents for information on it would be
Hillary cave would be up there with the
Republican Party commissioning that
reports in the Republican Party it was
it was a Republican organization yeah it
was a guy who hated Trump some hedge
fund billionaire didn't like Trump and
then the Hillary people are still who is
a he's a well he's a renowned British
intelligence agent by the way Grassley
and Graham it's criminal yeah they have
him in open court yeah you can open more
information I think they might be afraid
to hear at all
flip thank you good to see you good to
see you